we
have become as americans very
inward-looking in 2020. there were so
many things
happening whether you're talking about
the pandemic or the presidential
election
or the backlash against china did we
sort of miss something
in india what is your third talk
or your third prediction because i think
something rather large happened
there in 2020 and where is this headed
because when you look at demographics
at last check india's got more people in
china and a better demographic
composition of their population as well
yeah maybe maybe so i've had over the
last few years i've been doing these
predictions
these five-year rolling predictions
since 2015.
and in years past i said india is going
to be the world's fastest growing large
economy they're on fire their
demographic profile looks fabulous
i then went further and i said you know
what actually technology's coming forth
automated manufacturing the make in
india campaign will in fact
attract manufacturing but they're not
going to get jobs and india is going to
be the biggest disappointment there is
in the world because actually this
logic that economists of the world have
used for so long which is
there's this demographic dividend cheap
labor is useful
is broken that that actually is upside
down
we need to think of india as not having
a demographic dividend or a demographic
tailwind
but instead as a demographic headwind or
a noose around its neck
why do i mean what do i mean by that
well lots of young people means you
better produce lots of jobs
and we're not talking about you know
so it's a development strategy shift
that needs to take place
here's what i mean china may have been
the last large economy
that took the farmer to the factory the
production went from
10 bushels of wheat to a thousand ipads
and those gains were then shared a
little bit back with that worker who
went and became a consumer producing a
consumer society
right that industrialization based
development strategy
i think is now broken particularly
on scale and india needs a development
strategy
at scale and so the illiterate
unskilled indian farm worker is now
competing against a robot that doesn't
complain
that works around the clock that doesn't
have religious holidays or protests etc
and that when he makes a mistake the
engineer corrects it
and he doesn't make the same mistake
again ever
right and so i'm really nervous about
the long-term prospects for the
emergence of a large indian middle class
i think it's a hope you know tim cook
said china was great india is the next
china
i have to laugh at that the average
indian the
gdp per capita is somewhere in the 2000s
but the iphones are costing what a
thousand bucks these days are almost
i mean half of an annual salary of an
average indian and you think you're
going to sell millions of these things
no will there be a market yes will it be
a big market yes
is it the next china no so that's number
one
now to the to the more recent prediction
i made which was india becomes
geopolitically important
i think this is really interesting uh
obviously i think so i'm biased
but um india had an armed conflict with
china this this past year we
a lot of people didn't pay attention to
that you know in the in the border areas
where they have
disputes there were guns fired and
people
died this is between two nuclear armed
powers by the way
we might have remembered last year india
had similar conflicts with its
other neighbor pakistan which is also a
nuclear-armed power
and so this is really an interesting
part of the world and i would argue
potentially becoming as interesting as
any other part of the world from a
geopolitical and national strategy
perspective
and i think the us will come to conclude
that india can be a countervailing force
in that part of the world
against uh just china right i mean sort
of we can
help have a influence in that region
to combat the chinese influence that's
been growing and by the way it can help
also with the pakistan relationship but
it has the potential to lead us
very much into conflict with india's
traditional patron saint which is
russia um and so that creates some
complications but
it's something to watch well i'll be
keeping it on my radar
and i'm hoping for next year uh you can
tell us all how that india can finally
build out its infrastructure
i once tried to explain to somebody that
the the multiple
of highways in china was so big i needed
an extra large screen on my calculator
and they're like
that's impossible there's so many people
there and i'm like no there really is
there are no highways
it's very funny you bring up
infrastructure in india daniel i uh
um i once on a panel i was giving in the
middle east um
they asked me oh well of course the make
in india campaign is to be fabulous it's
going to change this story right they're
going to have all these jobs and
creation i said that's fine you can make
in india but the infrastructure is
such that you won't be able to get it
out of india
you